bonjour notre quartier c'est le bonheur
regarde des nouveaux voisins offrir
étudiants on va bien s'entendre
on est avec chroniques ou salut leekens
à puce
allez annecy quand est ce que tu m'as
choi trésor c'est un ballon c'est pas un
ballon
y a coûté bonbon je lui son désolé je me
sentais inspiré obligé de l'arracher
maintenant bon coup de reins il gicle au
monde de quoi ravir la marre de vos jeux
débiles
pourquoi vous êtes déguisé en robert
deillon c'est à moi tu parles playboy
sauvage vous vois venir
moi je vous observe je vous observe sur
nick et mon ballon s'est jeté sur voirie
mon futur ' il nous sous-estiment ils
veulent la guerre ils vont l'avoir
vous n'avez pas ce qui nous attend
bienvenue en enfer les chiottes je crois
qu'ils ont forcé la portière de la
voiture est volée les airbags rideaux